This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个IHeart播客。百分之百真人。你是否有愿望去真正发挥作用？LaCite学院为你提供“依赖症与心理健康”项目。掌握相关能力
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the challenges. Construise a career enriching to service of the community francophone of all the
这些能力对于陪伴和支持面临挑战的人至关重要。为服务于该国所有法语社区建立一份丰富的职业生涯。如果不知道是否有法语支持，可以通过CIT实现。请访问CollageLacacacac
country. Don't know the support in French, it's possible with the CIT. Visit CollageLacacacac
www.C. D.M. 这是加拿大法语健康培训联合会的一项倡议，得到了加拿大卫生部的支持。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。
www.C. D.M. An initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Health Supporting, supported by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes.
它们变黑了。这把我吓坏了。恶魔，醒醒。我是那个看到克里瓦克和德皮波实施谋杀的女人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处
They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being
最高刑罚后显得镇定自若。我说我没有罪。我要把这带进坟墓。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骨谷》中的“恶魔采石场”。快乐至关重要，它也难以捉摸，但现在有一个令人兴奋的新方法来开启你走向更快乐生活的旅程——《快乐101》。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。
sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby.
如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播聊天。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。由CVS呈献的霍达·科特比的《快乐101》。每个人都视我为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每一天我仍在学习
If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbe is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning
如何与自出生以来就伴随我的问题、错误、人际关系和情感共处。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每一件事都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这只是一些关于生存意义的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯，请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。
how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-Ornandez and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast.
如果你住在洛杉矶，你大约89%的生活都是在车里度过的。所以，我们把它变成了一个播客。在《你需要搭车吗》中，我们接上我们的喜剧演员朋友，在洛杉矶四处兜风，并讨论我们周围世界正在发生的事情。汽车对骑自行车的人非常粗鲁，但在这种情况下，是一个骑自行车的人故意阻碍交通。你所做的只是把车窗摇下来。他差点撞到那个。
If you live in L.A., you already spend about 89% of your life in a car. So, we turned it into a podcast. On Do You Need a Ride, we pick up our comedian friends, drive around Los Angeles, and discuss what's happening in the world around us. Cars are very rude to bicyclists, but in this case, it's a bicyclist going out of his way to get in the way of traffic. All you did was roll your window down. He almost hit that.
这就像一个脱口秀节目，但时速达到了30英里。每周一在Exactly Right Network上播出新集。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《你需要搭车吗》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的巨大变化、重要时刻和转折点，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目。正如我们当然要剖析的，二十岁时的心理学。你们知道的，这个播客的整个使命，就是把真正的研究、科学和研究带给
It's like a talk show, but going 30 miles an hour. episodes every Monday on the Exactly Right Network. Listen to Do You Need a Ride on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. You guys know the, like, the entire whole mission of this podcast is to bring, like, true research and science and studies to the experiences
我们在二十岁时经历的那些具有挑战性的、烦人的、令人困惑的经历。前几天我突然有了这样一个领悟，或者说顿悟，那就是我们从来没有做过关于求职面试的内容，这让我感到很疯狂，因为谁在二十岁时没有经历过很多次求职面试呢？求职面试其实是求职过程中的一个极其重要的部分。而且我也深知它具有多么深厚的心理学意味。如果你不相信它比其他任何事情都更具心理学色彩，这一集将会给你带来真正的震撼。我们正在讨论求职面试让人感到如此令人生畏的三大心理障碍或原因。第一印象的心理学以及根据研究如何留下良好的第一印象，
that we go through in our 20s that are challenging, that are annoying, that are confusing. And the other day I had this realization, an epiphany, if you will, that we had never done one on job interviews, which is wild to me, because who hasn't had a lot? had a job interview on their 20s. It's actually a huge part of the job hunting process. And I also know how deeply psychological it is. And if you don't believe me that it is probably more psychological than anything, this episode is going to be a real shocker. We are talking about the three biggest psychological hurdles or reasons. Job interviews are so daunting. The psychology of first impressions and how to make a good first impression, according to the
如何在求职面试中伪装自信而不显得虚伪，以及基本上如何利用我们对大脑、人格、社会心理学的了解来展示最好的自己，并希望在下次你发现自己重新开始求职时顺利获得工作。这是一集内容厚重的节目。我不想在我们的开场白上浪费更多时间了。让我们进入求职面试的心理学。首先，为什么求职面试会让我们如此紧张？我认为这是三个因素在同一个关键时刻交织在一起的结果。首先是我们对社会认可的需求，特别是来自权威人士的认可。
research, how to fake confidence in a job interview in a way that doesn't seem insincere, and your guide to basically leveraging everything we know about the brain, personality, social psychology to show off your best self and hopefully get the job the next time you find yourself back on the job hunt. It is a big episode. I don't want to waste any more time on our intro. Let's get into the psychology of job interviews. So first things first, why do job interviews make us so nervous? I think it's three factors, kind of all combining at one critical moment. It's our need for social approval, for one, especially from somebody with authority.
其次是我们对被评估的恐惧。最后，在这场面试中表现出色将决定其他对我们真正重要的因素，比如收入、工作稳定性，甚至是身份认同。基本上，其心理、情感和生理上的利害关系都非常非常高。让我们逐一探讨这些因素以及它们是如何导致我们的紧张情绪的。首先，当我们去参加求职面试时，会感觉我们的整个生活、我们作为一个人的全部本质都在以一种极不自然的方式受到评估和审视。这非常让人紧张，尤其是因为它需要我们放弃很多控制权，并接受别人对我们在那些对我们感觉非常重要的事情上产生错误的看法，
It's our fear of being evaluated second. And finally, it's that doing well in this interview is going to determine other factors that are really important to us, like income, job security, even identity. Basically, the stakes are psychologically, emotionally, physically, very, very high. Let's talk about each of these kind of factors one by one and how they contribute to our nerves. Firstly, when we go for a job interview, it can feel as if our whole life, our whole personhood is being assessed and scrutinized in a way that is very unnatural. It's very nerve-wracking, particularly because it requires us to give up a lot of control and to be okay with someone perceiving us incorrectly on things that feel very important to us,
比如我们的智商、我们的个性、我们的职业道德、我们的讨人喜欢程度。我们知道，归根结底，第一印象大约40%取决于我们，60%取决于另一个人的态度、经历和信念。而这可能会触及关于被评判、被拒绝或被比较的可能性的核心创伤。它也让我们非常清楚地意识到那种时刻包围着我们的社会等级制度，但它一下子变得非常清晰。这个人可以决定我们的未来和我们的生活，因为他们拥有权力，而在那个时刻，我们没有。所以这并不是一种很好的感觉。
like our intelligence, like our personality, like our work ethic, like our likeability. We know that at the end of the day, first impressions are about 40% us, 60% the other person's attitude, experiences and beliefs. And this can tap into core wounds around the possibility of being judged or rejected or compared. It also makes us very aware of the social hierarchy that kind of surrounds us at all time, but it comes into focus very clearly all at once. This person can determine a lot about our future and our life because they have power, and in that moment, we don't. So it's not a very nice feeling.
我认为拥有这种压力感是再自然不过的事情了。在许多方面，我们依靠社会认可来巩固我们的身份认同。这被称为自我验证理论。我们希望别人以我们看待自己的方式来看待我们。而在求职面试中，这并不总是感觉容易控制。我们争取社会认可的尝试之一包括练习印象管理，即我们预料哪些行为会在我们的社会环境中引发哪些反应，并展示出似乎能为我们提供最佳社会反馈的行为。
This is only natural, I think, to have this sense of stress. In many ways, we rely on social approval to strengthen our identities. This is called self-verification theory. We want others to see us the way that we see ourselves. And in a job interview, that doesn't always feel easy to control. Part of our attempt to garner social approval includes practicing impression management, where we anticipate which behaviors will provoke which reactions in our social environment and we exhibit the behavior that seems to offer us the best social feedback.
这种印象管理本能在求职面试中会增强上千倍，因此，当你面对一个处于权力地位的人时，你的精神负担会更加筋疲力尽。面试官或面试官们对你是否被录用有着直接的决定权。这会产生大量的社交焦虑。我认为更重要的是，在一个非常基础的层面，我们真的很需要一份工作。我们需要它带给我们的金钱。这不仅仅是为了好玩，对吧？所以，当我们的未来财务安全掌握在这个或这些人手中时，
That impression management instinct is like a thousand times more intense during a job interview, and therefore the mental load is more exhausting when you're in front of somebody who is in a position of power. The interviewer or the interviewees, like they have a direct say over whether you are hired or not. That creates a lot of social anxiety. I think what's more on a very fundamental level, like we really need a job. We need the money that it provides us. It's not just for fun, right? So when our future financial security is in the hands of this person or persons,
并且它掌握在我们在此情境下的表现时，如果事情开始失控，会让人感到极度的无助。即使谈不上金钱，而是出于对新挑战或更有成就感的工作场所的渴望，即使与财务无关，我们内心深处也有一部分人想要表现好，想要获得成就感，因为我们出于某种原因、无论出于什么原因在争取这份工作。获得这份工作也与我们的自信心、自尊心紧密相连。当我们把对自己的信念和自信寄托在外部事物上时，顺便说一句，这本来就是很自然的，
And it's in the hands of how we perform in this situation. It can feel extremely helpless if things start to get away from us. Even if it's not the money, but it's the desire for a new challenge or a more fulfilling workplace, even if it's not about finances, there is part of us that wants to do well and that wants to be fulfilled because we're going for this job for some reason, for whatever reason. Getting the job is also deeply tied to our self-confidence, our self-esteem. when we place our self-belief and our confidence in external things, which is only natural, by the way,
如果事情出了差错，如果这次求职面试搞砸了，要从那种状态中恢复过来就会变得更加困难。不幸的是，当我们承受压力并知道自己的表现正在被评估时，我们往往更有可能表现得更差，更容易结巴、说错话、以我们不想的方式回答问题。这并不仅仅与求职面试的表现有关。这方面的例子数不胜数。你知道，比如运动员、音乐家、电视节目主持人，他们在最后关头怯场，甚至当他们在做一件已经做过一千次的事情时，也是因为压力以及想要做好的这种适得其反的影响。我们以为想要做好能让我们表现得更好。
if they go wrong, if this job interview goes wrong, it's harder to recover from that. The unfortunate thing is when we're under pressure and know that our performance is being evaluated, we often are more likely to perform worse, more likely to stumble, say the wrong thing, answer questions in a way we don't want to. this doesn't just relate to job interview performance alone. There are countless examples of this. You know, for example, sports people, musicians, TV presenters who choke at the last minute, even when they're doing something that they've done a thousand times because of the pressure and the counterintuitive influence of wanting to do well. We think wanting to do well makes us perform better.
而当它达到几乎令人不堪重负的程度时，它实际上会让我们表现得更糟。这种反应也有心理学证据。2001年的一项研究将60名本科生分为两组。两组都被要求完成一项他们已经练习过的高尔夫推杆任务。其中一组被置于低压力条件下。他们基本上只是被告知要玩得开心，像平常一样完成任务。另一组被告知他们的表现将被评估。他们因表现出色而获得了一定的经济奖励。在这项实验的某些版本中，他们甚至被告知，你知道，他们的结果会影响他们的朋友，并会影响他们合作的伙伴。所以这增加了一些社会压力。
It actually makes us perform worse when it gets to a point of, almost being overwhelming. There is psychological evidence for this reaction as well. A study from 2001 split 60 undergraduate students into two groups. Both groups were asked to complete a golf putting task that they'd already practiced. One group were put under the low pressure condition. They were basically just told to have fun, to like complete the task normally. The other group was told that their performance would be evaluated. They were offered a fine, financial incentive for doing well. And in some versions of this experiment, they were even told that, you know, their result was going to affect their friends and was going to affect the person they were
你可能不会对此感到惊讶。在高压条件下操作的那组表现明显更差，这些条件模仿了求职面试的许多情况。他们的准确率下降了。有趣的是，在之前属于该组中技能较好的人当中，能力下降最为显著。在压力下，参与者开始过度监控他们的动作。他们开始有意识地控制一项本应是自动化的、他们已经练习过的技能。那些把高尔夫推杆练习当成无所谓的小事、当成纯粹好玩、有趣、充满挑战或令人兴奋的参与者的表现则更加流畅。
partnered up with. So that added some social pressure. Probably not going to surprise you here. The group who operated under the high pressure conditions, which mimicked a lot of the conditions of a job interview, performed significantly worse. Their accuracy dropped. And interestingly, the decline in ability was most significant in those who had previously been the more skilled of the group. Under pressure, the participants began to over-monitor their movements. They began to consciously control a skill which they'd practiced that should have been automatic. The participants who treated the golf putting exercise like it was no big deal, treated it like it was just fun, or enjoyable or a challenge or exciting, their performance flowed easier.
那么为什么呢？尽管有这一切，尽管这个时刻如此重要，为什么我们还是会觉得我们进入了那些怯场的时刻呢？我们在面试中，真的很想表现好。为什么当这件事对我们如此重要时，我们会觉得我们的大脑在与我们作对？我们需要了解的是：压力和压迫感是两个不同的概念。压迫感指的是外部的挑战以及需要我们能力的要求。而另一方面，压力则是我们对这种压迫感的心理和生理反应。单纯的压迫感本身无所谓好坏。压力反应才是将其转变为对我们有助益还是无助益的东西。
So why? Despite all of this, despite the importance of this moment, does it feel like we enter those moments where we choke? We're in this interview, we really want to do well. Why does it feel like our brain works against us when this thing is so important to us? Here is what we need to know. Stress and pressure are two distinct things. pressure refers to the external challenge and the demands that require our abilities. Stress, on the other hand, is our psychological and physiological response to this pressure. Pressure alone is neither good or bad. The stress response is what turns it into something that either aids us or doesn't.
当我们承受压力时，人类大脑会释放皮质醇和肾上腺素等荷尔蒙，这些荷尔蒙会为我们的身体做好战斗或逃跑反应的准备，以便让我们保持警觉。我们的瞳孔放大，我们的反射处于紧绷状态，我们的听觉变得更好，我们的心脏为快速逃跑或快速移动做好准备。当我们的大脑适量释放这些荷尔蒙时，这是一件极好的事情。我们可以改善记忆力。我们可以增强解决问题的能力。我们感到更加专注，几乎像进入了一种心流状态。这是一种带电的感觉，而这正是我们通常表现得非常非常好的时候。然而，当压力持续很长时间或者压力过大，或者我们对压力的压力反应
When we're under pressure, the human brain releases hormones like cortisol and adrenaline, which prepare our body for a fight or flight response so that we are alert. our pupils are dilated, our reflexes are on edge, our hearing is better, our heart is ready for a quick getaway or quick movement. When our brain releases these hormones in moderate amounts, that's a great thing. We can improve our memory. We can enhance our problem solving skills. We feel more focused, almost like in a flow state. It's like an electric feeling, and that's when we often perform really, really well. However, when the pressure is sustained for a prolonged period of time or is too much, or our stress response
过大时，皮质醇会积极地损害我们前额叶皮层的运作，这意味着我们的决策能力会直线下降。这就是所谓的耶克斯-多德森定律。耶克斯-多德森定律最早是在20世纪的一项研究中提出的，该研究基本指出，我们的绩效会随着轻微的压力而改善，但仅限于一定程度，一旦达到上限，我们就会崩溃。所以，当你去参加这个求职面试时，你的感官会变得高度敏锐。随着你感觉到压力某种程度上在上升，你解决问题的能力可能会有所提高。我们表现得很好，状态很流畅，但一旦它越过临界点，我们就无法跟上，我们的表现就会下降，我们开始变得非常焦虑和紧张。此后，回想起来可能会非常非常
towards our pressure is too much, cortisol can actively impair the functioning of our prefrontal cortex, meaning our decision-making tanks. This is known as the Yerkes-Doddson law. The Yerks-Doddson law was first coined in the 1900s in this study that basically states that our performance improves with slight stress, but only up to a certain level, before there is a ceiling, and we crumble. So going into this job interview, your senses are heightened. Your problem solving skills might improve as you feel the pressure kind of rise. We are doing really well, we're flowing well, but once it tips, we can't keep up and our performance to clients and we start to get really anxious and nervous. Afterwards, it can be really really
艰难，心想：天哪，我们本可以做得更好。反思所有不正确的回答、我们的耽搁和焦虑是件很容易的事。但你必须意识到，局势带来的压力最终战胜了我们。耶克斯-多德森定律适用于所有人。这是全人类的普遍规律，甚至连最具经验的运动员、公众演讲者、演员、医生，无论你举出谁的名字，当我们在该情境下的自我期望变得无法掌控时，都会经历这种状况。听着，求职面试后进行反思是很正常的，尤其是因为你可能不得不等待结果，而这种等待有时会比面试本身更让人难受。心理学告诉我们，在不确定状态下运作实际上是我们能经历的在心理上最具压力的事之一，
rough to think like, my God, we might have, we could have done better. Like, it's very easy to ruminate on all our incorrect answers and our delays and our anxiety. But you have to realize that the stress of the situation gets the better of us. The Yerkes-Dodson law applies to everyone. It is a law for all humanity, even the most practiced athletes, public speakers, actors, doctors, you name it, experience this when expectation for ourselves in the situation becomes unmanageable. Listen, it's normal to ruminate after a job interview, especially because you are likely having to wait for an answer, and that waiting can sometimes be more uncomfortable than the interview itself. Psychology tells us that operating in a state of uncertainty is actually one of the
包括在等待一场重大面试的结果时。研究表明，我们甚至可能宁愿接受一个负面的结果，也不愿面对一无所知的巨大不确定性。这就是我们对可预测性的偏好程度。我们宁愿发现自己没有被录取，也不愿多等一会儿来听听到底有没有被录取。但你也无法总是相信在等待期间浮现的想法，尤其是那些想要说服你“这一切都糟透了”以提供一种心理闭环的负面想法。基本上，真相是你的大脑在寻找任何形式的答案。如果它能告诉你，这一切都很糟糕，这种闭环会让你感觉良好，哪怕它并不准确。
most psychologically stressful things we can experience, including when waiting for the answer from a big interview. Studies show that we may even prefer a negative outcome over the uncertainty of not knowing. That is how much we prefer predictability. We would rather find out that we didn't get it than wait a little bit longer to hear if we did. But you also can't always trust the thoughts that emerge during this waiting period, particularly our negative thoughts that would like to convince you that this all went terribly in order to provide a sense of closure. Basically, the truth is your brain is looking for any kind of answer. And if it can tell you, this went bad, the closure of that is going to make you feel good, even if it's not accurate.
研究表明它很可能并不准确。1984年的一项特定研究对参与者进行了与其社会判断相关的实验。基本上，他们是否知道，能否准确评估自己？为了做到这一点，他们让人们对自己的表现以及他们认为自己做得好或不好的生活方面进行评分。他们注意到的是，当他们问参与者是如何得出这些结论的时，比如，我快乐吗，我做得好吗，我在这种情况下做得好不好，还是不好？他们的判断实际上并没有触及明确的证据。相反，他们写道，通常情况是，
Studies show it's probably not. One particular study from 1984 conducted experiments on participants related to their social judgments. Basically, do they know, can they accurately assess themselves? To do this, they had people score their own performance and aspects of their life that they thought they were doing well in or not. What they noticed is that when they asked participants how they came to these conclusions, like, am I happy, am I doing well, did I do well in this situation or no, their judgments don't actually tap into explicit evidence. Instead, they wrote that it's often the case that the
这种判断是在问题提出时根据他们那一刻的感受而形成的。因此，如果你刚刚结束了一场紧张的求职面试，或者正在等待电子邮件或回电，这种期待很可能会影响你的情绪，以至于你对自身表现的自我评估看起来比实际情况还要糟糕。这种自我评估是基于你的情绪的。而在一场你被社交评估的求职面试之后，你的情绪大概不会是最好的。即使你没有意识到，比如也许你正靠着肾上腺素支撑，比如也许你很焦虑，在那一刻，你很容易就会认为我表现得太糟糕了。我只是请你或许可以想一想，也许事实并非如此。好了，我们在这里
judgment is developed at the time the question is asked based on how they're feeling in that moment. So if you've just finished a stressful job interview or you're waiting for an email or a call back, the anticipation of that probably is impacting your mood so that your self-assessment of your performance seems worse than it actually was. That self-assessment is based on your mood. And your mood is probably not going to be the greatest in the aftermath of a job interview where you were being socially assessed. Even if you don't realize it, like maybe you're running on adrenaline, maybe like you're anxious, it's so much easier for you to think I did so terribly in that moment. I'm just asking you to maybe think that maybe that's not the case. Okay, we're going
做一个短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，让我们来谈谈你在求职面试中肯定能做些什么来表现得更好，以及一些关于管理自信、紧张情绪所有这些事情的技巧。请继续收听我们的节目。骄傲就像爱。你能在心中感受到它。IHeart Radio，加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括IHeart Pride Canada，你最喜欢的热门歌曲和必听的派对神曲，加上个性化和精选的播放列表，如当年的骄傲。聚在一起，庆祝爱。随时随地携带骄傲。只需让您的智能音箱播放IHeart Pride Canada。
to take a short break here, but when we return, let's talk about what you certainly can do to be better in your job interviews and some tips for managing, confidence, nerves, all those things. Stay with us. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio, Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists like back in the day pride. Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHartPride Canada.
在我们的手机上流媒体播放。立即在iHeartRadio.ca收听。在那一刻，感觉好像持续了永恒。我以为我活不成了。吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变黑了。
Stream us on your phone. Listen now at iHeartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。敢说这是你职业生涯中最大的案子吗？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀一个孩子。糟糕透顶了。我想是的。
It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so.
人们醒醒。我就是那个看到克里瓦克和德皮波实施谋杀的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得镇定自若。我说我没有罪。我要把这带进坟墓。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔采石场》。
People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevent and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并且为了在Apple Podcasts上收听无广告且包含独家内容的《恶魔采石场》，请订阅Lobif for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《由霍达·科特比主持的快乐101》的主持人。在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话。就像当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她是如何克服严峻的健康挑战时一样。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌。而那更加困难。
And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Lobif for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world. most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer. And that was more difficult.
有很多人理解产后抑郁症。我却没有为产后焦虑做好准备。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听由霍达·科特比主持的《快乐101》。这也是因为他们的新星是哈维尔·T·塔里托·埃尔南德斯。每个人都视我为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与自出生以来就伴随我的问题、错误、人际关系、情感共处。而且我还有这么多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？
There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's a part of it's because their new star is Javier T. Tarito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death?
你怎么处理取消文化？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常和普通到深奥和非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每一件事都是自发的、真实的和真诚的。这个播客就像是与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈，脆弱感流露出来，阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和教训被分享。
How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends Where vulnerability comes out Conspiracy theories end up on the table And goals and lessons are shared
在这生活中有一个完美的秩序，一切都只是等待我，我将能够连接我们在这里是为了连接。查理托·昂·哈维尔·埃尔南德斯，与IHeart Radio一起我们将让平凡变得非凡，保持关注。这是一个carac。哇
In this life has a order perfect and all is just Wait me, I'm going to be able to be able to connect We are here to connect The Chicharito On Javier El-Randes and together with IHA Radio We're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary, Stay close. It's a carac. Wow
请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》主流媒体充斥着对无家可归者的残酷描写，这些故事充满羞辱和指责，并将无家可归者描绘成铁板一块。《我们是无家可归者》是一个正在改变这种状况的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，创始人和主持人，多年来我创造了一个空间，让无家可归者和他们的倡导者能够讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去的几个月里，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQIA+社区以及制定影响无家可归者生存的法律的决策者。
Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast Mainstream media is full of cruel depictions of the unhoused, stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The Un-House is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator and host, and for years I've created a space where the unhoused and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed Un-House parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence.
《我们是无家可归者》是一个两度荣获韦比奖和西格尔奖的节目，未来还有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。本周收听我对吉奥·威乔尔博士的采访，她是一位由街头医生转型为网红的医生，她对无家可归者社区的工作在网络和她的社区中产生了巨大影响。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我们是无家可归者》。那么根据社会心理学研究，在求职面试中是什么给人留下深刻印象的？
Wheatian Houses a two-time Webby and Signal Award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Gio Wichor, a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Wheatley-House on the I-Hard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. So according to social psychology research, what impresses people in job interviews?
让我们来看看这一点。除了基础的东西，除了资质、能力、过往经验，人们真正在乎的是什么？我想具体谈谈第一印象的作用以及自信的作用，以及它们在求职面试中有多么重要。
Let's look at that. Besides the basic stuff, besides qualifications, competence, past experience, what do people actually care about? I want to talk specifically about the role of first impressions and the role of confidence
这不会让任何人感到惊讶。第一印象是影响求职面试结果的最重要因素之一。事实上，关于它的研究相当疯狂，当你真正深入其中时，简直可以说是不可思议。一个人会在见到你的五秒钟内决定他们是否喜欢你。事实上，2000年曾有过一项研究，让一组参与者观察59场不同的求职面试开始时，两位面试官与候选人之间的初次打招呼。
and how important those are in job interviews. It's not going to surprise anybody. First impressions are one of the most significant factors that influence the outcome of a job interview. In fact, the research on it is pretty wild, like pretty insane when you really get into it. A person will decide if they like you within five seconds of meeting you. In fact, there was a study from 2000 that had a group of participants observe an initial greeting between two interviewers and a candidate at the start of 59 different job interviews.
然后参与者离开了。他们没有被允许观看面试的其余部分。实验人员随后让面试官们基本上做出如下表态：你愿意雇用这个人吗？现在，这是一场假的求职面试，但他们被要求根据你所看到的专业技能、行为，你觉得怎么样？同样根据这些评估，无论真假，你认为谁会得到这份工作？
Then the participants left. They didn't get to watch any more of the interview. And the experimenters got the interviewers afterwards to basically be like, would you hire this person? Now, this was a fake job interview, but they were like, based on what you saw, professional skills, behavior, what do you think? Based upon these evaluations also, fake or not, who do you think would get the job?
现在，第一组只观看了面试极小一部分的参与者，从敲门到候选人坐下后五秒钟，他们能够以极高的准确率准确判断他们看到的那个人是否得到了这份工作。就像极高的准确率一样。令人难以置信的是，他们从如此短暂的片段中获得了关于这个人将如何被评估或他们是否会是一个好的候选人或他们是否能得到这份工作所需的一切信息。
Now, that first group of participants who were only shown a tiny portion of the interview, you from the knock on the door to five seconds after the candidate sat down, they were able to accurately determine whether or not the person they saw got the job or not with extreme accuracy. Like extreme accuracy. What's incredible is that they got everything they needed to know about how this person would be assessed or whether they would be a good camera. or whether they would get the job from such a brief, brief snippet of time.
这项研究真正暗示的是，特别是在求职面试的背景下，招聘经理对申请人的技能、知识、能力的评估，或者仅仅是他们实际上有多喜欢这个人，可能早在面试官和候选人最初的打招呼时就已经确定了。你在最初这几分钟内的举止，可能恰恰是整个对话中最重要的一部分。然而，这项研究可能也说明了，并且可能揭示了，偏见如何导致人们做出即时决定，但却不一定是最好的决定。尽管第一印象很重要，但研究也表明，它们实际上可能对人类处理信息和评估他人呈现出一种非常关键的局限性，因为它们 A，呈现出确认偏误，并且 B，
What the study is really suggesting is that, particularly in a job interview setting, a hiring manager's assessment of an applicant's skills, knowledge, ability, or just how much they actually like this person, might be fixed as early as that initial greeting between the interviewers and the candidate. how you hold yourself in those first few moments may just be the most important part of the entire conversation. However, what this study might also say is, and what it might reveal, is how biases cause people to make immediate decisions, but not necessarily the best decisions. As much as first impressions matter, research has also revealed that they may actually present
往往是基于人们对我们的熟悉程度或相似程度，或者与我们认识的人相似，或者与我们对好候选人的版本或想法相似，而不是基于谁实际上会成为最好的候选人。这不是基于我们，而是基于他们，是基于面试官。为什么会这样？为什么我们会不公平地依赖第一印象以及它们可能提供或可能不提供的错误信息？这是因为我们是社会性动物，对吧？即使在专业环境中，即使在我们知道不应该这样做的时候，我们也想相当快地对某人有一个了解，以便迅速预测对他们的期望。问题在于，在这种情况下我们并不理解我们的偏见。我们根据非常微小的事情来建立这些第一印象，比如微观肢体语言信号、姿势、某人嘴巴的位置、他们的气味、他们动作的快慢、眼神接触、语调，当然还有一般的身体外表、吸引力、种族、身体结构。
a very critical limitation to how humans process information and assess others because they, A, present a confirmation bias, and B, are often based on how familiar or similar people seem to us or similar to somebody that we know or similar to our version or idea of what a good candidate is rather than who would actually make the best candidate. It's not based on us, it's based on them, it's based on the interviewer. Why is that? Why do we unfairly rely on first impressions and the false information they may or may not provide? It's because we're social animals, right? And even in a professional setting, even when we know we shouldn't do it, we want to get a read on someone rather quickly in order to rapidly anticipate what to expect from them. The thing is, we don't understand our biases in that situation. We based these first impressions on really small things like micro-body language signals, posture, the positions of somebody's mouth, their scent, how quickly or slowly they move, eye contact, tone, and of course general physical appearance, attractiveness, race, body composition.
这意味着，即使你在所有其他方面都做得很好，有时某人也会不公平地只从一开始就按照他们想看到的方式来看待你。然而，我并不希望我们对此感到过于绝望。我们可以在求职面试中通过抓住某人第一印象的核心以及他们真正在寻找的东西来操纵这一点。从心理学的角度来看，他们寻找的是熟悉感和自信。熟悉感可以通过热情展现出来，带着开放的态度、友好、进行眼神接触、带着淡淡的微笑走进来，这个微笑似乎在说，你知道，嘿，我不是个威胁，
This means that even if you do well in all other ways, sometimes someone unfairly only sees you as they want to see you from the very beginning. However, I don't want us to despair too much on that. We can manipulate this in a job interview by getting what is really at the core of somebody's first impressions and what they're actually looking for. What they are looking for from a psychological perspective is familiarity and they're looking for self-assurance. Familiarity can be displayed through warmth, coming in with an openness, a friendliness, making eye contact, having a slight smile that says, you know, hey, I'm not a threat,
你喜欢我，我可以成为你们的一员。1981年的一项研究发现，一个人通过非语言沟通方式表现出的情绪越丰富，他们就越有可能被视为具有吸引力、迷人、熟悉。其他需要记住的关键事情，如果适用的话，做一些研究，了解人们在该公司日常通常穿什么，并穿得好像你已经是员工一样。再次强调，你看上去很熟悉。忽视，我早就知道这个人，这个人跟我本来就能合得来。当谈到求职
you like me, I can be one of you. A study from 1981 found that the more emotionally expressed of somebody is through the use of non-verbal modes of communication, the more likely they are to be perceived as appealing, attractive, familiar. Other key things to remember, if this is applicable, do some research on what people likely wear day to day at the company and dress like you are already an employee. Once again, you look familiar. ignores, I already know this person, this person and I could already get along. When it comes to job
面试时，评估你的人基本上在想，我想和这个人坐在一起八个小时吗？我觉得我有可能与这个人建立心理和社会的信任吗？我们是否已经有了理解的基线？我认为他在这个工作岗位上会对我有利吗？在这种情况下，闲聊也非常非常有用，只要健谈就能发挥奇效，因为同样，这会向这些人提供更多关于你的信息，让他们觉得熟悉并感觉他们了解你。这也显示了拥有多元化招聘小组的重要性，我要说的是，因为一个面试官，仅仅一个人的偏见就能毁掉一切。我认为这是从这项研究中获得的一个非常关键的收获。
interviews, the person assessing you is basically wondering, would I want to sit next to this person for eight hours? Do I feel like I could potentially build psychological and social trust with this person? Do we already have a baseline of understanding? Do I think there being at this job, it's going to benefit me? Small talk in these situations also really, really helpful, just being chatty, does wonders, because, again, it gives these people more about you to be familiar with and to feel like they know you. Also shows the importance of having diverse hiring panels, I will say, because one interviewer, just one person's prejudice can spoil everything. I think that's a really critical thing to take from this research.
接下来是自信或自信心，甚至是假装的那种。这在求职面试中非常重要，因为研究表明，尽管人们依赖他们自己的所谓直觉。他们也依赖这种隐性信念，即我们显然比他们更了解自己。因此，他们倾向于信任我们展示自己的方式是准确的。基本上，如果你不自信或者你认为自己不知道自己在做什么，那就假装自信。而且很有可能他们无法分辨出区别。这实际上来自于关于约会的研究，该研究表明，没有照片但自信编写的约会资料总是表现得更好，并使个人看起来更讨人喜欢，因为我们相信这个人，再次强调，
Next is self-assurance or confidence, even the fake kind. This is really important in job interviews because research shows that as much as people rely on their own so-called instinct. They also rely on this implicit belief that we obviously know ourselves better than them. So they are inclined to trust how we present ourselves as accurate. Basically, if you don't feel confident or you don't think you know what you're doing, fake it. And it's very likely they won't be able to tell the difference. This actually comes from research on dating, which shows that dating profiles that have no pictures but are confidently written will always do better and make an individual seem more likable because we trust that this person, once again,
有我们还看不到的自信理由。我们相信他们对自己的评估是准确的。走进房间时想着，我知道这些人会喜欢我。我知道我很适合这份工作。我知道我是谁。我知道我在做什么。我知道我有天赋。我知道我喜欢我自己，这种心态通过微小的无意识事情向外扩散，这些事情甚至可能连你自己都不知道自己在做，但却被面试官解释为自信，并有助于形成他们至关重要的第一印象。考虑到这一点，我也认为完善求职面试的一个绝佳技巧是进行一点正念自信练习，让你进入这样一种心态：我在这里会表现得很好，
has a reason for that confidence that we can't see yet. We trust they have an accurate assessment of themselves. Walking into a room thinking, I know these people are going to like me. I know I'm a good fit for this job. I know who I am. I know what I'm about. I know I'm talented. I know I like myself, that expands outwards through small unconscious things. You may not even know you're doing that are interpreted by the interviewers as self-assurance and help form their vital first impression. With that in mind, I also think a great tip for perfecting a job interview is having a bit of a mindfulness confidence exercise that gets you into the mind frame of, I'm going to do well here,
我每一次都要充满自信。这就是我们所说的情感锚定或情感北极星。基本上，这就是自我调节。如果你每次都有某种能触发你某种心境的行为，那真是太棒了。呼吸练习，4-4-4法则是一个经典。观看能让你进入状态的YouTube视频也是一个绝妙的策略，它将永远存在，你可以抓住它并让你感觉更好。
I'm going to be confident every single time. This is what we call an emotional anchor or an emotional North Star. Basically, it's self-regulation. If you have something that you do every time that triggers a certain state of mind for you, that is amazing. Breathing exercise, the 4-4-4 is a classic. Watching a YouTube video that gets you in the zone is also a great strategy that is always going to be there and you can grasp onto it and it can make you feel better.
我有一个朋友，她在进入求职面试之前会观看奥运会决赛。你可以称之为安慰剂效应。她告诉我这有助于她表现得更好。这可以是一首歌。可以是你每次面试前都有的一个常规动作。我还有另一个朋友，我非常喜欢这个，她在去面试之前，会想象她见过的所有最讨人喜欢、最有领袖魅力的人，并想象与他们握手。这可以是金色光球法，我们在播客中一直在谈论这个，你想象着，每一次吸气和呼气，你都在滋养这个来自你胸膛的金色光球，随着它变大，它用一种具有感染力的能量包围着你周围的每个人，让他们喜欢你，
I have a friend who watches Olympic finals before she, enters into job interviews. Call it a placebo effect, if you will. She tells me that it helps her do better. It could be a song. It could be a routine you have before every interview. I have another friend who, and I love this one, she pictures all the most likable and charismatic people that she's ever met and visualizes shaking their hands before she goes into an interview. It could be the Golden Orb method, which we talk about on the podcast all the time, where you imagine, like with every breath in and out, you're feeding this golden orb that is coming from your chest and as it gets larger, it surrounds everyone around you with an infectious energy that makes them like you,
并把他们吸引到你身边。这就像这个，这个魅力气泡。无论它是什么，这些仪式都利用了那种情感锚定效应。它们还利用了感知控制。这是由一个叫朱利安·罗特的人在60年代提出的概念，他基本上说过，任何能让我们觉得我们对一个可能我们几乎无法控制的情况或对我们的命运有控制的事情，任何能让我们觉得，你知道，我们有发言权的事情都会改善表现，比如这样的练习，无论它们是否起作用。如果它能帮助你在情感上进行调节，以便你能够以更好的情感策略和更大的自信去以你想要的水平表现，那么它是不是安慰剂其实真的没有关系。
like, and draws them into you. It's like this, this charisma bubble. Whatever it is, these rituals, they leverage that emotional anchoring effect. They also leverage perceived control. This is the concept that was labored by a man called Julian Rotter in the 60s, and he basically said, anything we can do that makes us feel like we have control over a situation that we probably have very little control over or over our destiny, anything that makes us feel like, you know, we have a say will improve performance such as exercises like this, whether they work or not. It really doesn't matter if it's placebo if it is helping you emotionally regulate so that you're able to go in with better emotional strategies and greater confidence to perform at the level
第二，在关于是过度准备还是准备不足的辩论中？永远要过度准备。有个叫尼古拉斯·鲁林的家伙。他是那本书的作者，我想那本书的名字就叫《求职面试心理学》。他说，有时当我们接受工作面试时，我们把它当作警察审讯，我们觉得自己好像做错了什么，而他们的工作就是找出证据。我们觉得自己正在被面试官审讯，他们想要找到我们过去的错误证据，证明我们为什么不能胜任。就像在这种情况下，面试官掌握着权力，而我们有点希望
you want to. Second, when it comes to the debate, is it better to under or overprepare? Always overprepure. There's this guy he's named Nicholas Rulin. He's the author of the book, I think it's literally called the Psychology of Job Interviews. And he said that sometimes when we are interviewed for a job, we treat it like it's a police interview and we treat it like we've done something wrong and it's their job to find out what. We feel like we are being in interrogated by the interviewer, and they want to find evidence of problems with our past, evidence of why we wouldn't be capable. Like in that situation, the interviewer is the powerholder, and we're kind of hoping that
你想这样做。第二，关于辩论，是准备不足更好，还是准备过度更好？永远要过度准备。有个叫尼古拉斯·鲁林（Nicholas Rulin）的人，他是《求职面试心理学》一书的作者，书名大概就是这个。他说，有时我们在面试工作时，会把它当作警察审讯一样对待，觉得自己好像做错了什么，而对方的工作就是找出我们的错。我们感觉自己像是被面试官审讯，他们想找出我们过去的过失证据，以及我们无法胜任的证据。在这种情况下，面试官掌握着权力，而我们有点希望
they're not going to punish us. They're not going to discover something bad about us. So we almost feel like we enter needing to get our story straight when actually we should be preparing to find out what we need to know about them, their culture, their recent history, their objectives, their workplace environment, recent moments, recent decisions that their company has made, whatever it is. Rulin, that same author, also notes that, on the other hand, some people underprepure in job interviews because they think it's going to be very casual and they think that
他们不会惩罚我们，也不会发现我们的坏毛病。所以我们几乎感觉自己进去的时候就需要把话理清楚，但实际上，我们应该准备去了解我们需要知道的关于他们的事情、他们的文化、他们最近的历史、他们的目标、他们的工作场所环境、最近发生的事、他们公司最近做出的决定，无论是什么。鲁林（Rulin），也就是同一位作者，也指出，另一方面，有些人在面试时准备不足，因为他们认为面试会非常随意，而且他们觉得
over-preparing jinx as things or, you know, gets certain answers to set in stone. And we also feel like we're going to be let down. This means that they're less likely to convey true qualifications that they have. They're more likely to come off as a little bit relaxed, a little bit flippant. It might not be clear that they actually want the job, that they actually are in it. What's important is that most interviews sit somewhere in between, right? You're not being interrogated, but also this isn't a casual affair. Knowing that it's going to sit somewhere in the middle helps you prepare.
过度准备会带来厄运，或者你知道的，把某些回答定型。而且我们也会觉得自己会失望。这意味着他们不太可能表达出自己真正的资质。他们更有可能表现得有点放松、有点轻率。可能无法表现出他们实际上想要这份工作，他们确实投入其中。重要的是，大多数面试都介于两者之间，对吧？你不是在接受审讯，但这也不是一件随随便便的事。知道面试会介于这两者之间，有助于你做好准备。
firstly you need to realize that nobody is out to get you, especially not in a job interview. Like it's serious, but it's not that serious. I think just being in the room in the first place is a sign that you've already impressed them, right? I always think this before I go into a job interview. They wouldn't waste their time if they didn't seriously think you were a good fit. Like if that first stage, they've already seen something they like about you, they're not going to waste their time. Now show them what needs to be known about you. Now show them the greater depth and now it's your turn to learn about them. Make it clear you know what the company actually does. Research exactly what someone in your role would be doing. Say what I expect to be doing. Say it out
首先，你需要意识到没有人要刻意为难你，尤其是在面试中。这虽然很严肃，但也没那么严肃。我认为，能进到这个房间本身就说明你已经给他们留下了深刻印象，对吧？每次去面试前我都会这么想。如果他们不觉得你真的很合适，就不会浪费时间。既然第一阶段他们已经看到了你身上他们喜欢的地方，他们就不会浪费时间。现在，向他们展示你需要让他们了解的自己。现在，向他们展现更有深度的一面，接下来轮到你去了解他们了。明确表示你知道这家公司到底是做什么的。具体研究一下你这个岗位的人会做什么。说出你期望做的事情。大声说
loud. Like I expect I'll be doing lots of this. Give examples of when you've done stuff like that in the past. Consume the content that the company has made that they're putting out on their LinkedIn, on their Instagram. Get a sense of the people who, who, makes decisions, how has it grown over time? I think what's more by researching the company and coming up with a set of kind of conversational narratives that align with what they're looking for. You can also situate yourself in the interview in a way that is chatty and confident, which we already know is important, but conveys you've planned for this, that like you know what you're talking about. Speaking of planning, if there is one question, they are definitely
出来。比如我期望会做很多这样的事情。举出你过去做过类似事情的例子。关注公司在领英、Instagram上发布的内容。了解那些做决策的人是谁，它是如何随着时间发展的？我认为更重要的是，通过研究公司并想出一套符合他们需求的对话叙事。你还可以以一种健谈且自信的方式来应对面试，我们已经知道这很重要，但这传达出你为此做过规划，而且你对谈论的内容了如指掌。说到规划，如果说有一个问题，他们绝对
going to ask you in every single job interview, it is, tell me a little bit about yourself. You need your answer to that question to be tight, to be distinct, to be under two minutes. And luckily for you, there is a little bit of a formula. Firstly, talk about education. When did you go to school? Then the two jobs you worked before the one you currently had all your most previous job, just mention them by name and by title, then go in depth on your most recent experience, including how long you've been there, highlight two major things you did in that role that you're
会在每一次面试中问你，那就是：请简单介绍一下你自己。你对这个问题的回答需要精炼、明确、控制在两分钟以内。幸运的是，这里有一个小公式。首先，谈谈教育背景。你什么时候上学的？然后是你目前工作之前做过的那两份工作，或者你最近的一份工作，只说出公司名称和职位，接着深入讲述你最近的一段经历，包括你在那里待了多久，重点介绍你在那个岗位上做过的两件你引以为傲、证明你能力的大事，
proud of and that you're capable of, then where you see yourself going now and why that future vision aligns with this job. Also, what you're interested in outside of work. Once again, for that familiarity. That is literally the equation. Practice that to death. This is also one of the easiest ways to ease your nerves because you know they're going to ask you that question. And if you have your answer ready to go, you're going to nail it. First question, out of the gate, you're going to do great. When my boyfriend was applying for jobs at the start of the year, I made him rehearse that. So many times, I'm sure he got sick of me asking, but I think it helped.
然后谈谈你现在觉得自己的发展方向，以及为什么这种对未来的愿景与这份工作相契合。还有，你工作之余有什么兴趣爱好。再次强调，这是为了增加熟悉感。这简直就是个公式。把这个练习到滚瓜烂熟。这也是缓解紧张情绪最简单的方法之一，因为你知道他们会问你这个问题。如果你已经准备好了答案，你就会稳操胜券。第一个问题一开局，你就会表现得很棒。今年年初我男朋友申请工作时，我让他排练了
He's not here to confirm or deny. I think it helped because he had that question, like, ready to go. Okay, we need to take one more short break here, but I promise I have more psychological tips for your upcoming job interview when we come right back. You have the desire to help to make a real difference? The College of the City you offer the program Dependence and Scenti Mental.
无数次，我确信他都厌烦我提问了，但我认为这很有帮助。他没在这里确认或否认。我认为这很有帮助，因为他对那个问题做好了准备，随时可以回答。好了，我们这里需要再休息一小会儿，但我保证，当我们回来时，我还有更多心理学小贴士可以帮应对你即将到来的面试。你有帮助他人、带来真正改变的渴望吗？城市学院为您提供药物依赖与戒除项目。
Acqueray the competences essential for accompanying and to support the people confronted to and defy for a career enriching to service of the community
获得陪同和支持面临挑战的人士所需的必备能力，为服务社区提供丰富职业生涯。
francophone of all the country. Don't know of the quality in French, it's possible with the CET. Visit Collage LACC.A. right now. An initiative
全国法语。想精通法语？通过CET即可实现。立即访问 Collage LACC.A。这是一个由
of the consortium national of formation in health Souttened by Sante Canada. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes.
加拿大卫生部支持的国家卫生培训联盟发起的倡议。那一刻，感觉仿佛过了一个世纪。我以为自己活不成了。我吓坏了。那双眼睛里空洞无物。
They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets.
它们变成了黑色。把我吓了个半死。那是你的第一起谋杀案？是的，先生。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的一起案件吗？是的，先生。针对儿童的强奸谋杀案。可以说是最糟糕的情况了。
I would think so. People wake up. and saw the murder take place by Creveit and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我想也是。人们醒来，目睹了克雷维特（Creveit）和德皮波（DePippo）实施的谋杀。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）毫无悔意，被判处最高刑罚后也显得镇定自若。我说，我没有罪。我要把官司打到底。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼採石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。
And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety.
要想无广告收听《魔鬼採石场》并获得独家内容，请在苹果播客上订阅LaVa for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby），播客《霍达·科特比的快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby）的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话。比如当演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她是如何克服严峻健康挑战的经历时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过乳腺癌难关，那才叫真的艰难。很多人都懂产后抑郁。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。
Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's a ton of excitement because their new star is J. Chittarito
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。这里充满了兴奋，因为他们的新星是小豌豆（J. Chittarito）
Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player but before anything else I'm human. Every single
埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天
day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born.
我依然在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共处，从我出生的那一刻起。
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you
我依然有那么多的问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何
deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
应对取消文化？C罗还是梅西？有外星人吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？
From every day an ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared.
从日常的平凡到深邃的不凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像是与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈，脆弱感流露无遗，阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和人生教训得以分享。
All in this life, has an order perfect and all is just. Wait me, I'm going to pressuram, but me will go to be going to connect. The Chicharito. And Javier El Chicharito Hernandez, and together with Ica Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary.
生命中的一切，都有完美的秩序且一切皆显公正。等等我，我要施压，但我要去连接。小豌豆（The Chicharito）。
Stay close. It's a carac. Listen to learning to be human On IHad Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture,
我是哈维尔·埃尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯（Javier El Chicharito Hernandez），我将与伊卡电台（Ica Radio）一起，将平凡化为不凡。敬请关注。这是一个特质。在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Champs》播客中，我们正在与文化界最热门的名字对话，
like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped, like, 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now. Like, that's the rate we gotta be going.
比如斯韦·李（Sway Lee）。你意识到自己有多传奇吗？我很感激。我看到了，但我心里想，天哪，我还有好多好多事情要做。就像普林斯（Prince）一样，他发了大概30张专辑。我们现在才发了大概五张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。
Yep, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fab Five Freddy. I directed when Nas' early videos. Which one? One love. Wow. I literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge.
没错，这态度很好。你还将听到来自行业传奇和嘻哈先锋的故事，比如法布·5·弗雷迪（Fab Five Freddy）。我导演了纳斯（Nas）早期的MV。哪一个？《One Love》。哇。我真的在他在昆斯布里奇（Queensbridge）的公寓里拍摄的。
His moms were still up in that apartment. Nas was just beginning to take off. His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know, conscious stuff, and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drinkchamps brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
他妈妈当时还在那个公寓里。纳斯才刚刚开始崭露头角。他爸爸以前住在哈林区（Harlem）离我不远的地方。他爸爸把他领进了很多，你知道的，有意识的东西的世界，造就了一个年轻的天才。无论哪个时代，《Drink Champs》都会为你带来最大牌的人物和最原汁原味的对话。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《Drink Champs》。
Okay, we talked about the importance of having an emotional anchor before the interview, but research also shows that people who pause before answering questions or have an anchor in the moment, sometimes called a power pause, by the way. people who have that notion to take a couple of seconds to give a considered response come off as more prepared, more calm, and they answer questions better. They also use fewer filler words like, um, like, I guess, those kind of things. There has been some research, I will say, that suggests answering immediately and quickly and just like getting, just saying something immediately makes you seem more truthful. there was one 2021 study that was like, oh, maybe if you answer quicker, people are going to like you more because you seem more honest. But they were talking about pauses up to 10 seconds.
好了，我们讨论了面试前拥有一个情感锚点的重要性，但研究也表明，在回答问题前稍作停顿，或者在当下拥有一个锚点的人（顺便说一句，有时被称为“力量停顿”）那些有意识花几秒钟给出深思熟虑的回答的人，会显得更有准备、更冷静，而且他们对问题的回答也更好。他们还会减少使用诸如“嗯”、“像”、“我猜”这类填充词。我得说，确实有一些研究表明，立即、快速地回答问题，或者马上说点什么，会让你显得更诚实。2021年曾有一项研究表明，哦，也许如果你回答得更快，人们会更喜欢你，因为你看起来更诚实。但他们讨论的是长达10秒的停顿。
Like if you take 10 seconds to answer a question, that might be a little bit much. Two seconds, though, is not a lot. And two seconds is a lot for your brain, though, right? Two seconds doesn't seem like a lot for the interviewer. For you, you're going to have thousands of thoughts subconsciously in that two seconds. and allowing yourself a little bit more time to sort through them subconsciously means that collecting your thoughts, thinking about it, just having a quick plan of how you're going to answer means you're going to come off better.
比如如果你花10秒钟来回答一个问题，那可能有点太长了。不过，两秒钟并不算多。但对你的大脑来说，两秒钟已经很长了，对吧？对面试官来说，两秒钟似乎不算什么。而对你而言，在这两秒钟里，你的潜意识里会有成千上万个想法。允许自己多一点时间在潜意识里对它们进行梳理，这意味着收集你的想法、思考并对如何回答做一个快速的规划，会让你表现得更好。
You're not going to panic and say something that you don't mean just to fill the space. You're not going to say something you just think the interviewer wants to hear. You're going to really be considered. And you're going to also show personally by pausing a kind of emotional restraint and a caution and a care that people probably want in somebody that they're hiring. You're not just showing that you are good at answering interview questions. You're showing that if you were to get the job, whatever situation you're going to be in, you are going to have a considered approach.
你不会惊慌失措地说出言不由衷的话仅仅为了填补空白。你不会说那些你以为面试官想听的话。你会真正经过深思熟虑。而且通过停顿，你也会亲自展现出一种情感克制、谨慎和细心，这正是人们在招聘时希望在应聘者身上看到的。你不仅仅是表现出你擅长回答面试问题。你是在表明，如果你得到了这份工作，无论身处什么情况，你都会采取深思熟虑的方法。
You're going to have that pause, think clearly, strategize mentality. So power pause is such like a girl boss, like boss babe title, like name for something. but think of it as just like that emotional anchor you have before you go into the job interview. It is your moment to kind of come back into yourself and really think how are we going to put our best foot forward here and actually convey what we want to convey rather than just what our anxiety wants us to convey. Okay, let's get into some rapid fire tips for you to finish off this episode just to leave you feeling prepared for what you've got. coming up, things that like, just very quick, you can apply, hopefully, instantly if you need it. Number one, before you go into a job interview, loosen every single muscle in your face and then raise them again and smile. This is a physiological tip that people swear by. Why does it work? Because
你会拥有那种停顿、清晰思考、制定战略的心态。所以“力量停顿”这个词听起来就像是个职场女王、职场大佬风格的名字。但你可以把它仅仅看作是你在去面试前拥有的那个情感锚点。这是你找回自我、认真思考我们如何在这里展现出最好的一面，并真正传达我们想要传达的内容，而不是只传达焦虑想要我们传达的内容的时刻。好了，让我们进入一些快问快答的小贴士，为这集节目做个结尾，让你对接下来的挑战感到准备就绪，这些小贴士非常简短，如果你需要的话，希望可以立即派上用场。第一，在去面试前，放松脸部每一块肌肉，然后再次提拉并微笑。这是一个备受推崇的生理学小贴士。为什么它管用？因为
your body and your brain are in constant communication. When we're anxious, the muscles in our face tighten almost automatically, especially around your jaw, around your forehead, around your eyes, and around your mouth. Your nervous system interprets that tension as evidence that something is wrong and that can instantly intensify feelings of stress and threat. By consciously interrupting that, relieving those muscles, you interrupt that feedback loop. Smiling also has a fascinating psychological effect known as the facial feedback hypothesis. This is the idea that our facial expressions don't just reflect emotions. They can also influence. They can also influence emotions. So if you ever heard the thing, if you're sad, just smile for 10 seconds,
你的身体和大脑一直在不断沟通。当我们焦虑时，面部肌肉几乎会自动收紧，尤其是下巴、前额、眼睛和嘴巴周围。你的神经系统会将这种紧张感解读为有什么不对劲的证据，这会瞬间加剧压力和威胁感。通过有意识地打破这种状态，放松这些肌肉，你就打断了那个反馈循环。微笑还会产生一种迷人的心理效应，被称为“面部反馈假说”。这个观点认为，我们的面部表情不仅反映情绪，它们还能影响情绪。所以你是否听说过这样一种说法：如果你很难过，只要笑上10秒钟，
it will make you happy. It's actually true. Even a forced smile can reduce your stress response and signal safety to your brain. Number two, refer to people by name occasionally throughout the interview, especially when answering their specific questions. Firstly, this shows that you're speaking to them, you've remembered them, you know they're important. Secondly, there was a 2006 study that found a lot of evidence that hearing one's own name has unique brain functioning activation, including in areas responsible for directing our attention. So basically, they're going to pay more attention to whatever you're saying. Finally, I think it creates more of a sense of dialogue and a back-and-forth type atmosphere,
它就会让你快乐。这其实是真的。即使是一个强挤出来的微笑，也能减轻你的应激反应，并向你的大脑发出安全的信号。第二，在面试过程中偶尔按名字称呼对方，特别是在回答他们的具体问题时。首先，这表明你在与他们对话，你记住了他们，你知道他们很重要。其次，2006年的一项研究发现大量证据表明，听到自己的名字会激活独特的脑功能区域，包括负责引导我们注意力的区域。所以基本上，他们会更加关注你所说的话。最后，我认为这会营造出更多的对话感和来回互动的氛围，
particularly during parts of an interview that can feel quite monologue heavy, like when you're answering long questions, when you're being asked to solve a a problem. Like, it can feel like it's very you and they can kind of tune out. People like to feel considered they like to feel seen. Using somebody's name is like the easiest way to do so and to grab their attention back so that they're not thinking about the next interview, thinking about the last interview, thinking about all the other stuff they have to do with their job. It makes them feel like, oh, this person knows my name. Again, that familiarity. Firstly, they've paid attention to me. I feel respected. I feel noticed as the interviewer, but also if they know my name, we must be on like a friendlier kind of basis, which kind of tricks them psychologically into liking you more.
特别是在面试中那些容易让人感觉像是长篇大论的部分，比如当你回答长问题时，当被要求解决一个问题时。这可能会让人觉得完全是你自己在说，而他们可能会有些走神。人们喜欢被体贴对待，喜欢被看到。使用某人的名字是最简单的方法，既能做到这一点，又能重新抓住他们的注意力，让他们不再去想下一场面试、上一场面试，或者工作中要做的其他事情。这会让他们觉得，哦，这个人知道我的名字。还是那句话，熟悉感。首先，他们关注了我。我感到被尊重。作为面试官，我感到被注意到了，而且如果他们知道我的名字，我们的关系一定更友好一些，这在心理上会促使他们更喜欢你。
Finally, have one to two questions prepared that you actually want the answers to that are also a little bit less obvious. Hopefully you're already doing this, but if not, having those questions and not just boring questions like questions that you just, you genuinely care about signifies a willingness to engage with the job and the company long term. And it shows deliberate planning in advance that you think that you're going to get this job and you think you're, like, you're really considering how you're going to fit in importantly and significantly. Think about what you actually want to know, though. Again, I keep expressing this, but if you just ask questions you think you're useful or like you think you're going to impress them, that you actually don't know the answers to, like it doesn't come off as very authentic.
最后，准备好一到两个你真正想要得到答案、且不太显眼的问题。希望你已经在这么做了，但如果没有的话，准备好这些问题——不是那种无聊的问题，而是你真心关心的、真正关心的问题——这表明你愿意长期投入到这项工作和公司中。这表明你提前进行了深思熟虑的规划，你认为自己会得到这份工作，并且你真的很认真地在考虑自己将如何完美而重要地融入其中。不过，要想清楚你到底想知道什么。再次强调，我一直在表达这一点，如果你只是问一些你认为有用或者能让他们印象深刻、但你实际上并不知道答案的问题，这看起来并不那么真实。
Ask things that once again you have genuinely been curious about, things that they genuinely would want to give you a good answer to. Here are some examples. Perhaps you'd like to know how much you can progress in the future, how flexible the working hours are, what opportunities they have for volunteering, employee engagement, personal development, something more lighthearted, like, what do you guys do for your company party? Maybe not that question, but like something that's just figure out what's something that they are not advertising or haven't made clear that you are really interested in
问一些你真正好奇的事情，那些他们真心愿意给你一个好答案的事情。这里有一些例子。也许你想知道未来能有多大的晋升空间，工作时间有多灵活，他们有哪些志愿服务、员工参与、个人发展的机会，或者一些轻松一点的，比如，你们公司的派对通常会做什么？也许不是这个问题，但就像是弄清楚有什么是他们没有宣传、没有说清楚，而你又真的很想知道、并且会影响你对这份工作的决定的事情。我还想提醒你们，面试和任何其他技能一样，需要一定程度的练习。现在的就业市场非常严峻，尤其是对于二十多岁刚步入职场或处于职场初期的人来说。即使你没有得到这份工作，即使你搞砸了，练习本身也是无价的，这只是你磨炼技能的又一次机会。试着掌握那个第一印象练习，也就是那段两分钟的“我是谁”的自我介绍。试着对自己好一点，记住每个人都会被拒绝。有时拒绝也是一种保护。被拒绝总比不去申请、不展现自己、不进入他们的视线要好。
knowing that's going to inform your decision about their job. I also want you to remember job interviews like any other skill require a level of practice. Like the job market is incredibly tough right now, particularly for people in their 20s entering the workforce or in like their early stages. Even if you don't get this job, even if you do screw up, the practice is invaluable in itself and it's just another chance to try out your skills. Try mastering that first impression exercise, that two minute, who am I pitch. Try and be kind to yourself and remember that like every single person gets rejected. Sometimes there is protection in rejection. And And getting rejected is better than not applying, not putting yourself out there, not putting
在每一次不如意的面试背后，转角处往往还有另一份有趣的工作或另一个有趣的机会，而现在的你或许刚好符合条件。还有一件事，我知道我刚才说“最后一件事”，但这绝对是最后一件事。即使你这次面试没有得到工作，并不意味着你和这家公司的缘故就此永远关闭了。你现在已经在他们的视线里了。
yourself on their radar. Behind every job interview that didn't go the way you want it to is another interesting job or another interesting opportunity just around the corner that maybe now you're available for. One more thing, I know I said one more thing, but definitely one more thing. Even if you don't get the job from this interview, it doesn't mean the door is closed forever with that company. you're on their radar right now.
我有一些朋友，在当初没能通过面试获得心仪岗位的六个月后，拿到了那里的工作。我认识的一些人，在以为自己搞砸了的面试中意外获得了更大更好的机会。我的朋友诺亚（Noah）在应聘一个完全不同的职位面试五个月后，居然拿到了苹果公司（Apple）的工作。就在上周，她就在上周签了这份合同，因为你永远猜不到。我坚信事情的发展永远不会如你预料的那样，包括面试，也包括求职。这是一个很好的提醒，不要轻易否定自己，也不要仅仅因为第一次可能没有成功就切断后路。
I've had friends who got jobs six months later from interviews that didn't land them the job that they actually went for. I've had people I know get other bigger opportunities from job interviews they thought they failed and tanked. Literally my friend Noah got a job at Apple five months after her interview for an entirely different role. Last week, like last week she signed this contract because you never know. And I do truly believe that things never happen the way that you predict them happening, including job interviews, including the job hunt. It's a good reminder to just like not count yourself out and to not burn bridges just because perhaps you weren't successful the first time.
显然，面试很重要。但还有其他因素会影响对一个人的评估。所以归根结底，你可能会有一场极好的面试。你可能给他们留下了深刻印象。但可能另一个人恰好有一年以上的经验，或者另一个人恰好认识公司里的某个人。因此，尽管你在其中付出了巨大努力，尽管你想要做好充分准备，但正如我们之前所说，期望越高，压力就越大，
Obviously, job interviews are important. But there are other things that do go into somebody's like assessment. And so at the end of the day, you could have an amazing job interview. You could have really impressed them. And somebody just had one more years' experience. Somebody just happened to know somebody in the company. So as much as you're putting a lot of effort into this, as much as you want to be prepared, we also know, as we said before, the greater the expectations, the greater the pressure,
你越容易被压力压垮。所以这可能是一个荒谬的建议。你可以听取，也可以不听。我知道这听起来很荒谬，但请把面试看作是一件本该有趣的事情，一件注定能让你作为一个个体成长的事。面试的另一头没有什么可怕的。你的唯一职责——我不想再用“工作”这个词了，
the more you are likely to feel overwhelmed by the stress. So this may be ridiculous advice. You can take it or leave it. I know it's going to sound, it's going to sound ridiculous, but treat job interviews as something that is meant to be fun and is something that is meant to be your chance to grow as an individual. There is nothing on the other side of the job interview. Your only, I don't want to say job again,
但你进入那场交流的唯一角色是了解更多关于对方的信息，了解更多关于这家公司的信息，测试你的技能，测试你的表现，不管最后这份工作是否属于你，拥有这种“我是来体验的，我是来学习的，我是来看看我能做些什么，看看我有什么能力”的心态，从整体来看，是一种更好的心态，它能减少那种最终可能会微妙地破坏你表现的期望感。这就是我今天要给你的所有建议。我对你抱有很大希望。祝你好运。我觉得你一定会表现得超级棒。听着，没有人喜欢面试，
but your only role in going into that encounter is to learn more about the other person, to learn more about this company, to test out your skills, to test out how you perform, whether the job on the other end is yours or not, having that kind of, I'm here to experience, I'm here to learn, I'm here to just see what I can do, see what I'm capable of, is a better mentality overall for reducing the sense of expectation that could actually end up subtly sabotaging how you perform. So those are all the tips I have for you today. I'm very hopeful for you. Good luck. I think that you're going to do amazing. Listen, nobody likes job
面试太糟糕了。糟透了。没有人喜欢坐在某人面前，在短短一个小时内，被评估你在乎的一切。所以如果进展不顺利，如果你最近经历了一次糟糕的面试，没关系。这只是生活的一部分。就像交税一样，就像死亡一样。面试就是有点糟。但我希望这些关于理解为什么你会如此 apprehensive（忧虑）的心理学小贴士、关于第一印象、关于自信、关于印象管理的建议，对你在做的任何事情都有用。如果你已经听到了这里并且正在Spotify上收听，请在下方留个言。你是不是正要去参加面试？你最近有面试吗？是什么工作？你目前在探索什么样的机会？
interviews. Like, they're awful. They suck. Like, nobody likes sitting in front of somebody and being assessed for, like, everything that is important to you in, like, an hour. So if it's not going well, if you've had a shit job interview in recent history, it's all right. Like, it's just part of life. It's like taxes. It's like death. Job interviews just kind of suck. But I hope that these tips in understanding the psychology behind why you are so apprehensive, behind first impressions, behind confidence, behind impression management is useful in whatever you're doing. If you have made it this far and you are listening on Spotify, leave a comment down below. Are you about to go into a job interview? Have you got a job interview going up? What's the job for? What do you, what kind of opportunities are you currently exploring?
大家都留个言吧，这样我们就可以祝你求职顺利了。我相信你一定能表现得极其出色。一如既往，如果你还没看的话，现在可以在Netflix上观看播客的完整剧集。你也可以在Instagram上关注我们：That Psychology podcast。我想我也要就此写一篇Substack文章。我觉得这会是个有趣的话题。所以请在Substack上关注我们。如果你想阅读这些小贴士、保存这些小贴士、以后以不同的格式查看它们。我想这就是我所有的时间了。再次感谢你一路聆听至节目末尾。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。
Let's all leave a little comment so we can wish you. good luck on your quest. I'm sure you're going to do amazing. As always, you can watch full episodes of the podcast now on Netflix if you haven't done so yet. You can also follow us on Instagram at That Psychology podcast. I think I'm going to make a Substack article about this as well. I think it would be an interesting one. So follow us on Substack. If you want to read these tips, save these tips, look at them later on in a different format. I think that's everything I have time for. But again, thank you for listening all the way to the end. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself.
祝你面试好运。我相信你绝对、绝对会表现得惊艳全场。你一定能大获成功的。我们很快就会再聊。那双眼睛里空洞无物。它们变成了黑色。把我吓了个半死。恶魔，醒来。
Good luck with your job interview. I'm sure you're going to do absolutely, absolutely killer. You're going to kill it. We'll talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up.
我是那个目睹克雷维特（Crevette）和德皮波（DePippo）实施谋杀的人。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）毫无悔意，被判处最高刑罚后也显得镇定自若。我说，我没有罪。我要把官司打到底。在iHeart Radio应用、Bone Valley Feed或你获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼採石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸，但现在有一个令人兴奋的新方法来开始你迈向更快乐生活的旅程：《快乐101》（Joy 101）。这是一个由
I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse. unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by
我——霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby）主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中对话。打开免费的iHeart Radio应用，搜索《快乐101》，立即收听。《霍达·科特比的快乐101》由
me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving, inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101, and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented
CVS呈现。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天我依然在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共处，从我出生的那一刻起。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。
by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine.
只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯（Javier Chicharito Hernandez），在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。如果你住在洛杉矶，你大约89%的生活都是在车里度过的。所以我们把它变成了一个播客。在《你需要搭便车吗？》（Do You Need a Ride）中，我们接上我们的喜剧演员朋友，在洛杉矶到处兜风，讨论我们周围世界发生的事情。汽车对骑自行车的人很不友好，但在这种情况下，是一个骑自行车的人故意挡在交通要道上。你所做的只是摇下车窗。他差点撞到那个。
Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tchariot Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. If you live in L.A., you already spend about 89% of your life in a car. So we turned it into a podcast. On Do You Need a Ride, we pick up our comedian friends, drive around Los Angeles and discuss what's happening in the world around us. Cars are very rude to bicyclists, but in this case, it's a bicyclist going out of his way to get in the way of traffic. All you did was roll your window down. He almost hit that.
这就像是一个以每小时30英里速度行驶脱口秀节目。每周一在Exactly Right网络播出新节目。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《你需要搭便车吗？》。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特（Michael Rappaport），我的播客《我是拉帕波特立体声播客》（The I Am Rappaport Stereo Podcast）与你听过的任何节目都不同。如果你在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何引起我注意的事情的强烈观点，那就赶紧订阅吧。这个叫杰法尔·杰克逊（Jafar Jackson）的孩子绝对、百分之百应该因为他饰演迈克尔·杰克逊而获得提名。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《我是拉帕波特立体声播客》。这是一个iHeart播客。
It's like a talk show but going 30 miles an hour. New episodes every Monday on the exactly right network. Listen to Do You Need a Ride on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rappaport Stereo podcast, is unlike anyone you've ever heard. If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rap Report on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast.
人类品质保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Guaranteed Human。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。